and fine finally new rules since america
is such an incredibly [ __ ] up place
right now
let's scale back our goal of making it
great again and settle for
let's just make the mall great again
just start with that and get a w and
i'll tell you why it's actually a bigger
win than you might think because online
shopping
is killing us
psychologically and environmentally do
you ever wonder why shopping through the
mail didn't become so big until this
century
of course the internet and smartphones
made it easier but the sears catalog was
founded in 1887. it was amazon just
amazon that never grew
people could have been getting
everything in the mail a century and a
half ago and often with a better reason
to because there weren't cars that made
going to the store so easy
why didn't they
i don't know but lately i've been seeing
a lot of stories about how isolated and
lonely people are
maybe it has something to do with that
in the golden age of the mall it was
often called america's town hall as
marketplaces have always been the center
of society
yes ours was a little tacky but it was
better than this
turns out ordering online is way more
echo unfriendly than driving to the
store ever was
how could it not be considering that
americans now shop by the most
inefficient means humanly possible since
we can't get our ass to go try something
on and see how it actually fits and
looks and feels we order nine
and send back eight
you have any idea the ecological [ __ ]
show that's caused just by making people
chauffeur your pants all over town
[Laughter]
you know back when people still went out
before brick and mortar stores were just
for shoplifting
people didn't shop every day
no no they they made these things called
shopping lists
words that corresponded to items they
needed
and then they went to the storer mall
and gathered all of these items on the
list at one time
as opposed to how we do it now where
robots and humans who are treated like
robots pack your little bag of
scrunchies in a box the size of a dog
house and deliver it to your home along
with three other giant boxes each
containing one item
how can you have a thousand types of
shoe horns but only three sizes of boxes
to put them in
where do we think all that packaging
goes we stuff it in blue bins like it's
a portal to plastic heaven but
only 14 of it is actually recycled the
rest goes into landfills incinerators
and the ocean
in 20 2009 america's most successful
investor warren buffett went big on
railroads
and everyone said warren you must be
senile come on we're living in the age
of streaming and ai and google glasses
and robot dogs
railroads
and warren said yeah but after all of
you are done clicking to get your garden
weasels and avocado slicers
[Laughter]
something has to actually get it to your
door
for some reason people just don't trust
a condom made by a 3d printer
good luck with dogecoin
so listen to this there's a vaping
device for pot that i i mean a friend of
mine
uses which has a feature that allows you
to turn it on from an app on your phone
even though it has a button right on the
side that works just as well
now i'm not knocking this thing i like
it i'm just not naming it on tv because
well if you want the benefit of
advertising i have a podcast and the ad
team would be happy to take your call
anyway
the point is anyone under 30 who sees
the app feature thinks it's the eighth
wonder of the world
because it doesn't work the old timey
way by pushing a button it's so cool
cause it's on the phone
hey kids get a [ __ ] clue
just cause it's on the phone doesn't
make it cool
we think we're super technologically
advanced when we push a button but every
time you click buy it now a tree gets
its wings
i know we don't want to think about the
kids that make it or the truck that
brings it or the landfill where it ends
up we just want that t-shirt that says
mindful
i know it's all so easy you clicked on
the picture of the hot dog toaster and
it appeared at your door
ready for you to toss in the garage
but it didn't come without a cost it
came across the pacific on a
diesel-powered cargo monster spewing
sulfur
the most downloaded shopping app in the
united states is a chinese company
called xi'an which produces 6000 new
styles a day and ships them direct from
their warehouse in guangdong to the 22
year old in your basement who thinks
they're an influencer
sheehan is part of a new industry called
fast fashion which specializes in
clothing that will absolutely positively
fall apart if you so much as look at it
wrong
and that's deliberate these clothes are
made cheap real cheap out of the
flimsiest materials because apparently
now gen z and millennials like to buy
clothes wear them once and throw them
away
the average u.s consumer now throws out
80 pounds of clothing each year
i hear a lot about how my generation has
ruined the environment i don't think
it's my generation that's doing this
and for what so you can hear someone say
nice dress is that paper
look
the cdc made it official last week we
don't have to stay six feet apart
anymore you're free to move around the
country we're no longer on active
sneezer alert
and they've turned off the titan your
[ __ ] sign
go out and play
go to the mall
our social skills are atrophying while
we one-click ourselves into oblivion
amazon's in its prime but you're wasting
yours
you